NOW, IN REAL LIFE YOU CAN HAVE
THE BEST OF TIMES AND WORST AT
TIMES BUT UNDER THE TRUMP OF
THIS MEDIA IT'S ALL BAD ALL THE
TIME.
THINGS ARE PRETTY GOOD WHEN THE
TOP STORYLINE GETS TROTTED OUT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ISOLATED
GOING MORE FURIOUS BY THE DAY.
HIS MOOD DARK AND ANGRY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS LASHING OUT
ON THE MUELLER PROBE.
>> HE WAS IN A FOUL MOOD.
>> HIS DATA MINE IS THE WORST
IT'S BEEN SINCE THE CAMPAIGN AND
THERE IS A NEAR UNIVERSAL SENSE
OF FOREBODING.
GREG: A UNIVERSAL SENSE OF
FOREBODING.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL AFTER EATING
TACO BELL.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT TRUMP IS MAD AND SO MAD THAT
MAYBE HE WILL STAGE A COUP.
>> IN EACH SEDIMENT HE DOES RUN
AND HE DOES LOSE IT WILL BE
STUDYING WHAT WE WOULD SEE I'M
NOT LEAVING CALL THE MILITARY.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS MAN.
GREG: I'M LOOKING AT THAT MAN.
FROM THAT, MSNBC EIGHT HIM IN A
LAB CHICKEN BUTTER IN BOTOX
PASTE.
NOW THAT THE APOCALYPSE HAS BEEN
POSTPONED TO A BRUNCH WE MUST
MAKE DO WITH THE OLD CHESTNUT,
TRANS UNSTABLE.
WITH SOME NETWORK STOP TALKING
ABOUT HOW THAT OF HIS WHAT ARE
YOU LEFT WITH?
THEM.
THE EMPTY TALKERS AND THE
NOISEMAKERS IN SUITS.
JAW CLACKING DOLLS WITH BROKEN
TUMMY TALKS AND BROKEN HINGES.
EVEN AS THE NEWS LOOKS GOOD FOR
AMERICA HE SCORED A HIGH
PARTISAN WIN ON PRISON REFORM
AND EVEN -- AGREES.
>> THE 99 TIMES I DON'T AGREE
I'LL GIVE HIM HELL BUT ON THIS
ONE I WILL GIVE HIM A SALUTE AND
APPLAUSE.
WE GOT TO COME TOGETHER TO
PEOPLE AT THE BOTTOM.
GREG: WHY THE MASS PRESS ODS HE
WANTED TO START OF PARK FOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.'S.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
>> THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED
STATES IS RACIST.
GREG: WELL, IF HE'S A RACIST
HE'S REALLY BAD AT IT.
TRUMP, THE WORLD'S WORST RACIST.
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA FOR A COFFEE
MUG.
WORLD'S WORST RACIST.
[APPLAUSE]
ALSO MISSED THERE WAS THE MEDAL
OF FREEDOM HONORS, GEORGE HERMA
HERMAN, BABE RUTH JUNIOR.
>> GEORGE HERMAN BABE RUTH
JUNIOR THAT HE WAS A JUNIOR.
GREG: I JUST LOVE THAT.
THEN YOU HAVE TRUMPS ARCH
HEMORRHOID STIMULUS CHASING
CHUCKLE BUCKET -- THIS IS NOT
FUNNY BUT BUSTED ON SUSPICIOUS
OF STRIKING WOMEN ALLEGEDLY BUT
OF COURSE THE CAT IS INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY AND THAT'S
WHAT GOOD PEOPLE BELIEVE IN EVEN
IF PEOPLE LIKE HIM DO NOT.
HE COULD BE INNOCENT, AS
INNOCENT AS BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS
WHEN AVENATTI WAS TORMENTING
HIM.
I JUST HOPE THE MEDIA DOES
SOUL-SEARCHING AFTER BOOKING
THIS CLOWN.
THE MEDIA SOUL-SEARCHING THAT
LIKE LOOKING FOR BIGFOOT.
[LAUGHTER]
IS NOT SO LONG AGO AVENATTI WAS
THERE DARLING.
CNN AND MS IN BC WERE A JUNKIE
TO TRUMP CRACK.
THE MEDIA THAT LOVES YOU TO
PRETEND YOU NEVER DATA.
IT MIGHT BACK STREET BOYS
PAJAMAS.
ABBOTT AND I NEVER OWN THEM BUT
FOR YEARS I WEAR THEM UNDER MY
SCHOOL UNIFORM WHICH LEADS ME TO
A NEW HUGE LANDMARK STUDY ON
MEDIA TRUST.
THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER SURVEYED
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ON WHO'S THE
MOST TRUSTED NAME IN NEWS.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY THE
SURPRISING ANGER WHO BLEW AWAY
THE COMPETITION SO WE WILL JUST
THROW TO THE CITY OF.
>> IN 2018 A LANDMARK POLL
SURVEYED AMERICANS TO DETERMINE
THE MOST TRUSTED NEWS MEDIA
PERSONALITY.
THE RESULTS ARE IN AND ONE OF
THE MOST TRUSTED NAMES IN NEWS
IS NONE OTHER THAN GREG GUTFELD.
JUST ANOTHER [INAUDIBLE] HE
BESTED THE MOST ESTABLISHED
INDUSTRY INSIDERS.
OTHERS WERE BAYLOR ABLE TO COME
OUT AHEAD OF GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S CLEAR THE REAL WINNER IS
YOU, AMERICA.
YOU GET TO WATCH MOST
TRUSTWORTHY CHARISMATIC AND
HANDSOME NEWS MEDIA PROFESSIONAL
SIX DAYS A WEEK.
JOIN US IN CELEBRATING
TELEVISION'S MOST PROLIFIC
BROADCASTER, GREG GUTFELD.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: THANK YOU.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
NO, STOP IT.
SCARBOROUGH, DEAD LAST, MAYBE HE
SHOULD OF STUCK TO WHATEVER HE
WAS DOING BEFORE TV.
>> WHEN WE GET THE CHECKS?
GREG: I ALMOST BEAT GENTLEMEN
AND CHRIS CUOMO.
>> SOBEY SENSITIVE.
NOT EVERYTHING IS ABOUT YOU.
>> I'M SORRY.
GREG: SOMEBODY LOOK LIKE HE
BETTER GET AFTER IT.
LIKE I ALWAYS SAY WHEN LIFE
GIVES YOU GENTLEMEN GO WATCH
GREG GUTFELD.
I ALSO BESTED RACHEL MADDOW.
HOW CAN THAT BE, RACHEL?
>> I USUALLY HAVE SO MANY WORDS
AND I HAVE THE BEST WORDS BUT
FOR THIS I HAVE NO WORDS.
DID THIS FIERCELY JUST HAPPENED.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: TO QUOTE RACHEL -- BUT
EVEN I HAVE TO ADMIT THIS IS
WEIRD.
SOMETHING WRONG WHEN I MORE
TRUSTED THAN WHAT WAS HER.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
HE'S BORING WHICH MAKES HIM
INSTANTLY TRUSTWORTHY AND I'M
FLATTERED BY THIS BUT TERRIFIED.
ME TRUSTED BY YOU?
I DON'T EVEN TRUST MYSELF.
I WON'T EVEN BE ALONE WITH ME.
BUT HERE'S THE REAL PROBLEM.
THE LIST HAD MIXED COMMENTATORS
WITH REPORTERS WHICH IS STUPID.
FNC HAS BOTH BUT WE CLEARLY
LABEL WHAT'S WHAT.
OTHER NETWORKS ARE THE SQUARE
WHICH IS WHY SOME OF THE PEOPLE
MISTAKE OPINION FOR A FACT WHICH
LEAD TO BIG NEWS.
NO WONDER PEOPLE THINK TRUMP IS
CRAZY OR INSANE BECAUSE IT'S AN
OPINION COMING FROM THEIR NEW
SOURCES AND THAT IS NOT HEALTHY
IF WE ONLY HAD SOMETHING FOR
THAT.
>> I'M NOT LEAVING.
CALL THE MILITARY.
TRUMP WILL ENGINEER A COUP.
HE WILL ROUND UP FAMILIES AND
SEPARATE CHILDREN.
HE WILL IMPRISON WOMEN AND TURN
THEM INTO BABYMAKING FAMILIES.
>> WHERE DID YOU COME UP AT
THIS?
>> WATCHING TV AND TALKING TO MY
FRIENDS.
>> SOUND LIKE YOU NEED NEW
FRIENDS BACK TELL ME MORE.
>> NEW FRIENDS IS NOT A DRUG BUT
A GROUP OF PEOPLE PRESENT A
DIFFERENT SET OF OPINIONS THE
MORE CLEARLY REFLECT REALITY.
>> SOUNDS GREAT.
WHERE DO I START?
>> FIRST, GO OUTSIDE.
THEN GO TO A HARDWARE STORE.
OR MAYBE A GROCERY STORE OR
LOCAL CHURCH.
NO PLAYGROUNDS.
THEN INITIATE CONVERSATION
WITHOUT MENTIONING POLITICS.
DO YOU HAVE NEIGHBORS?
TALK TO THEM ABOUT THE WEATHER,
SPORTS OR THEIR PETS.
THEY LOVE TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
PETS.
DO THEY LIKE YOU?
>> YES.
WELL, NO.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT OF RINGING
OVER A BOTTLE OF WINE.
>> NEW FRIENDS IS A GREAT WAY
FROM YOU GOING DOWN BUT RABBIT
HOLE.
GET NEW FRIENDS TODAY.
GREG: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST, PUBLISHERS GROVEL WHEN
YOU WRITE A NEW NOVEL, WALTER
KERN.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
HE'S A COMEDIAN BY NIGHT AND A
GUY IN HIS UNDERWEAR BY DAY,
WRITER AND COMEDIAN JOE DEVITO.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SHE'S MURKY, QUIRKY AND NATIONAL
REVIEW REPORTER KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
HIS STATURE IS ICONIC AND HIS
DINNER PLATE TECTONIC, FORMING A
WWE IN MY MASSIVE PSYCHIC,
TYRUS.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: YOU HAVE BEEN TRAVELING
THE COUNTRY AND GIVE US -- IS IT
AS DARK IS IT AS FOREBODING --
>> DOOMING THE MOOD OF THE
COUNTRY THE SAME AS TOM'S MOOD?
NO.
YOU GET OUT THERE AND PEOPLE WHO
DO NOT HAVE JOBS IN 17 YEARS ARE
LIKE CAN I BUY YOU LUNCH.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT HERE IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THEY DID THE PRESIDENTS WITH
ROBERT MUELLER CLOSING IN AND
NOW THEY MOVED ON TO THE FINAL
DAYS WHICH WAS THE NEXT
BERNSTEIN BOOK ABOUT NIXON AND
PORTRAITS LATE AT NIGHT SO IN
THEIR INABILITY TO IMAGINE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A NIXON
ALIEN PRESIDENT THEY ARE GOING
EVEN FURTHER.
GREG: ANY THOUGHTS ON AVENATTI?
>> NO.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: EXCELLENT.
>> THEY SAY HE LOOKS LIKE A
CERTAIN MALE ORGAN.
I'VE NEVER THOUGHT THAT.
THAT'S MY ONLY THOUGHT.
GREG: I NEVER THOUGHT THAT
EITHER UNTIL NOW, JOE.
YOU ARE NOT THE COUNTRY AND YOU
BEEN A SUDDEN.
>> YEAH, I'VE BEEN HOLED UP.
GREG: WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ANY TOPIC FROM THE MONOLOGUE?
>> IF YOU SAW AVENATTI PLANE AND
EVIL LAWYER IN THE MOVIE PACINO
WOULD SAY THAT'S OVER THE TOP.
I LIKE HOW DONNY DEUTSCH SAYS
DONALD TRUMP WOULD NOT RESPECT
THE RESULTS OF ELECTION BUT WHO
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE?
GREG: TRUE.
BY THE WAY, I LIKE YOUR BEARD.
CAT, WHAT YOU MAKE OF MY WORK?
IT WAS NOT AWARD BUT MY RATING
AS BEING ONE OF THE MOST TRUSTED
MAN IN NEWS.
YOU PROBABLY SAW THAT COMING.
KAT: I'M SO HAPPY TO SEE YOU
HAPPY, GREG.
ANYTHING ELSE?
GREG: NO.
THOUGHTS?
KAT: I'M SO GLAD THAT I'M NOT
THE PRESIDENT AND THAT I DON'T
HAVE EVERYONE IN THE MEDIA
ANALYZING MY MENTAL STATE ALL
DAY, EVERY DAY.
I WAS JUST LOOKING AT THAT
IMAGINING WHAT STORIES THEY SAY
ABOUT ME WHEN THEY BE LIKE SHE
WAKES UP EVERY MORNING NEXT TO
AN OLD BOBBLE HEAD DOLL LIKE SHE
MAKES US LISTEN TO RETURN OF MAC
ON REBATE DURING NATIONAL
SECURITY BRIEFINGS.
YOU KNOW,  I OWN 23 PAIRS OF
PENGUIN SOCKS.
WHY DOES SHE KEEP TWEETING ABOUT
LIZARDS AT 3:00 A.M. AND WHY
DOES SHE ALWAYS BE ALONE?
BUT THANKFULLY NOBODY KNOWS ANY
OF THOSE THINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: NO, NOT AT ALL.
WE KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
TYRUS?
ONE THING, YOU MADE AN EXCELLENT
POINT THAT STORMIE WAS FAR
BETTER BEFORE AVENATTI AND SO
THIS IS A GUY WHO RUINED WOMAN'S
LIFE.
TYRUS: SHE RUINED A PORN WOMAN
STAR'S LIFE.
THAT TAKES SKILL AND TALENT.
THEY HAVE A TOUGH JOB.
>> DOESN'T SHE STILL OWED TRUMP
MONEY?
TYRUS: APPARENTLY YOU WERE OUT
ON A MISSION BECAUSE WE COVER
THIS A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
WHEN SHE STARTED SHE WAS A
DIRECTOR.
SHE WAS GOING PLACES BUT SHE
WASN'T UNVEILING IN THOSE PLACES
BUT MIDDLE-MANAGEMENT.
SHE HAD GOT MONEY.
SHE SIGNED OR WAS ABLE TO MOVE
ON WITH HER LIFE AND THEN HE
CAME ALONG AND DRAGGED IT ALL
OUT AND HE DID TV SHOWS AND HE
GOT FAMOUS AND SHE GOT TWO
BILLS.
ONE FROM THE PRESIDENT AND ONE
FROM THE PANCREAS.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEN SHE CAME OUT AND SAID
IF THIS IS TRUE, I'M OUT.
EVEN IF IT'S NOT TRUE, STORMY,
YOU DON'T TAKE ADVICE, GET OUT.
GREG: IT'S --
GREG: IT'S.--
TYRUS: ONE MORE THING.
BECAUSE OUR PRESIDENT IS SO
TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT IS PIS
SED.
I LIKE PRESIDENT OBAMA DON'T YOU
DARE.
BUT I'M PRETTY SURE WHEN HE LOST
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE IT
WASN'T CHERRIES AND SMILED IN
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT DAY.
I'M SURE THERE WAS A LOT OF WHO
YOU LOOKING AT WHAT HE WANT ME
TO DO.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS WELL, HERE
WE GO, GATHER AROUND AND LET'S
SING SONGS TO ENSURE JOBS ARE
FRIEND AND HE'S LIKE -- I'M SURE
IT WAS AN UNHAPPY TIME.
FOR THEM TO SAY HE SO MAD.
THEY WANT HIM TO BE MET.
HE SHOULD PLAY IT OFF AND
SLAMMED THE DOOR AND WALK OUT
THE FRONT YARD AND SCREAM WHY
AND WALK BACK IN.
AND THOUGH STUFF AROUND.
LIVE IT UP, YOU KNOW?
GREG: WHAT THE IRONY HERE IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP TWEETED STORMY
DANIELS BETTER THAN MICHAEL
AVENATTI DID BECAUSE SHE GOT
PAID.
HE PAID HER AND IT WAS A
TRANSACTION THAT SHE WAS HAPPY
WITH.